if you are sort of wrestling with this
i'm actually kind of
okay with that because this is a part of
mathematics that we have not touched
for quite some time if that part of your
brain is just like full of cobwebs and
you're like
blow the dust off you're like ah
nothing's there okay that's actually
kind of why we're doing it
let's have a go can someone tell me and
by the way you won't see any degree
symbols here so hand me an answer in
radians please
can anyone tell me what alpha plus beta
is actually equal to
yeah go ahead yeah pi over
two pi over two is the correct answer
now if you're like
um where did that come from 90 degrees
if that's where your brain
feels more comfortable let's think about
some of what we know about the fact that
this is a
circle and therefore what can we infer
from it okay and we're really going real
basic like back to
year seven almost okay is this circle
okay so
being at this point here is marked in
which means it's the center
of the circle what can you tell me about
these
one two three intervals coming from the
center what can you tell me about them
they're all they're all equal they're
radii aren't they so maybe if you
haven't already
go ahead and mark that in onto your
diagram
okay now because these are
equal radii the triangles
like the sub triangles inside this trunk
so there's like a triangle here like a
flat looking one
and then this one over here in the top
right hand corner because they've got
radii forming the sides there what can
you tell me about the triangles
there say again they're isosceles thank
you so much so you've got
equal sides here equal sides here
equal sides are opposite equal angles or
you might have said
the base angle or base angles of an
isosceles triangle are equal
okay um i prefer equal signs opposite
equal angles because you don't even need
to say you need to prove that it's
isosceles you can just skip that logical
together
so if there are equal angles opposite
equal sides
this angle up here what's that this one
this
small this thin one this is alpha as
well isn't it right because these two
are opposite equal sides and then up in
this triangle you've got
that's that's beta right beta beta
whichever you prefer okay
now at this point where can my reasoning
go
well there's a bigger triangle i thought
that'd be sub triangles right
there's a bigger triangle that's
inscribed within
this circle and you know all of the
angles at all the vertices
of this big triangle right if you were
to add up
all of the angles there's three of them
right what would you get
one you should get 180 degrees because
it's a triangle
i'm thinking in radians mode so pi
radians so
that would be what it's all equal to but
if i actually go around
and take the angles that have been
presented here then
you got two alphas you've got two betas
and to get to the result that uh we had
calvin give us before we just have to
divide both sides by
two and that gives you pi over two is
that okay this makes sense so
like i said a bit of thinking about
sides triangles angles
and we're there please fire that away in
the back of your mind we're going to
return to it
shortly rule it off leave space
for a heading i'll give it to you in due
time and i'd like you to write down
the following equation underneath your
empty heading here it comes
argument of uh what i got here z
take away three zed take away one equals
pi
on 2. all right
now as before i just want to sort of
gauge
how many of you don't tell me or don't
shout out don't spoil it
how many of you looking at this equation
have
some sense any sense at all of what kind
of graph
we might draw on the basis of this
equation any takers
i just want to see a show of hands if
you've got something they already won
anyone else oh delightful okay here's
here's what we're going to do right
we're going to explore this is why i
left the heading empty right we're going
to explore what shape
you get out of this and it is a shape
you're familiar with but because we are
in complex numbers land
we can do some really cool things with
it all right so here's what we're going
to do first
when you have uh two complex numbers in
this case n minus three
and z minus one when you divide two
complex numbers one by the other
what happens to the arguments
we we subtract the arguments don't you
um we usually think about it in reverse
when you multiply multiply two complex
numbers we add the arguments well this
is just the same thing
in reverse do you agree so what i can do
is i can start to write this in a
simpler form i can tease it out a little
bit
by saying well the argument of that
first
complex number if you subtract
the argument of the second complex
number you'll end up with
the argument of the the quotient what
happens you divide are you okay with
that
that's so far so good okay great so
this is an alternative way to write the
same thing but
what does this mean okay have a think
about this with me
there's some complex number z it can
sort of like fly around the complex
plane
but i want it to be in exactly the place
where
if you measure the angle from three
we think about this from examples last
week right from three
to our complex number z and you take the
difference
with the angle measured from one to the
same complex number
apparently we want that difference
to be pi on two there are some points on
the complex plane where if you measure
from here
measure from here take the difference
you'll get this result now
that's a heck of a lot to keep in your
mind so
on your laptop go ahead open it up what
i'd like you to do
is go to the bottom of the page
on canvas and you should find
a desmos activity link that will take
you to look to something that looks
roughly like this not exactly
but pretty close okay
now as you're opening this up
right i want you to think about
what does this mean how can we
understand what's going on in terms of
this
equation okay
argument of z minus three what does that
mean
um i'm i'm calling our movable z
point i'm calling it p up the top there
so it sits in purple over there okay
so i can move this around and so can you
you can just put it anywhere you like
okay now the thing i want you to get you
want to get across to you right
is i'm trying to measure some angles
right i've put some protractors onto
here so you can see what's going on so
for example if i just look over here
at this side here if i put p at
somewhere like
let's put it there
have a look at the argument of z
minus three it's an obtuse angle
we measure from the positive real
positive direction of the real axis
right and then we measure anti-clockwise
i know it's a bit small but can you read
the angle off there
have a think it's from the positive side
right so it's an
obtuse angle you should be getting right
this is this 130 degrees right
i i couldn't find a protractor in
radians so we're just gonna have to deal
with degrees for a little bit okay
so that's 130 and then if i come over to
my other protractor
uh it's close and i'll i'll adjust it a
little bit so it's closer to something
precise
uh let's put it there okay so i've got
argument of z minus one over here on the
left-hand side
just reading the protractor what's that
angle that's uh
pi on three thank you that's 60 degrees
right now i've got both in degrees so
here if i were to take the difference
that's that's this right one angle take
away the other what did we say it was
130
take away 60. so what would be the
difference
in this case
that's 70 degrees right is that pi on 2
no it is not so this particular point
that i've chosen
doesn't satisfy the equation but if you
go ahead you can find points that do
right for example let me just uh move
this down a little bit
i'm going to try and put it about
that should do it have a look at the
angles i've chosen this time and maybe
you've chosen something similar right
what do i got over here i've got 140 on
the right hand angle
and i've got 50 on the left hand
angle is that okay it's 140 take away 50
bam bam i've got 90 degrees that's pi on
two radians so you're like ooh
whatever that spot is that's one of the
spots the one of the zeds
that satisfies this does this are you
following so far okay now if you just
have a look at the computer next to
yours if you've
found if your friend has also found a
point presumably it's not exactly the
same point
as what i've got right so there's a
whole family
of points the locus that will satisfy
this and we're trying to find all of
them does that make sense